dad one thing I talk a lot about is how
much you've worked right like my work
ethic completely inspired by you and mom
the way she worked the house but much
more you you know we really didn't hang
out and I think you know we don't think
to talk about what I got fired the one
time for two hours off another day off
love to ask to leave early for a high
school party you know when you graduate
high school people have parties I asked
on a Saturday to leave it five instead
of seven pm right right and I worked
every summer day these are like I asked
to leave at five instead of seven one
day and we believe the house at seven to
open the store so seven to five you know
we're 9:00 to 5:00 every day you know
two hours early hanging up on this one
hold on I gotta tell this story he
looked me dead in the face and said
you're not committed to the business
you're fired
she came home and he was crying and of
course he's more than I have to get
involved and then I was I went from
crying because I cried to smiling
because I actually didn't work the next
day
and since I've been working my whole
high school life I was like wait a
minute this is interesting little AJ I'm
not yet this was right second joke this
was playing the Rangers yes and so I was
like this is amazing and then might you
know my dad doesn't really green even
come to apologize he just walked into my
room the next day he goes
you couldn't you're coming to work I'm
like all right
you know what's so crazy because he was
such a absolute failure with academics
you can hold that over anybody who got
B's
you're letting you got B's dude you
square ask mother [ __ ] that got
jealousy he said it's so crazy how
entrepreneurship and like it's like
Gandhi like right in a bizarro world I'm
like [ __ ] this if I was $4,000 a weekend
when I was 12 right in 2017
I'd be like [ __ ] a genius the next
this I was getting [ __ ] on but everybody
yes I didn't read Catcher in the Rye
over the weekend so that's what we're
talking about do you pause because
you're like [ __ ] I read that in one hour
he keeps going he was like
there are you guys know this there's
like 15 videos in the IG video of him
being like I was a loser I was a loser
people call me a loser for getting D's
and F's
[ __ ] suck yeah here's something that
nobody else will tell you if somebody
goes to a restaurant for the first time
and has a flawless experience the
statistical likelihood of them doing a
second visit is about 40% they come and
have flawless experience the statistical
likelihood of a third visit is still
about 42% the third time they come the
statistical likelihood of a fourth visit
is over 70% so I got a market to three
visits not one visit one floor it dinner
you sit him down put a red napkin on a
table not a white one identify him as a
first-time customer connect with them
and work to get them back a second time
in the third time once they're there the
third time you own them mention that the
red napkin thing is genius because you
know in a fast-casual environment we're
not hitting that table honey but let me
give you like a snack in this red
channel
good okay so you put a red napkin at the
table Gary sits down he's eating dinner
now he's getting his free rib dinner
orders water costs them nothing I know
her a first-time customer because he's
got a red napkin when he's leaving and a
manager comes to the table writes on the
back of a business card five dollars off
chicken did you like the ribs love them
you gotta try my chicken come in for the
chicken now I'm prompting a second visit
not with a printed or out of hand card
now he comes in a second visit drops the
business card on the table everybody
knows this is a second visit because red
napkin was the first visit second visit
is the meal you go up you say so how is
the chicken it was freaking great
are you full totally stuffed man next
time you gotta try my cheesecake peas
free piece of cheesecake now three
visits rip squeeze a piece of cheesecake
on a piece not leave her cheesecake I
was like that's [ __ ] brilliant cause
the chicken was a washout just raise the
discount that's right the cheesecake is
at 35 for about six hours you got three
visits out of them with a 70% likelihood
of a fourth that's the way you're mark
in a restaurant with that wall
fuel for the four people that may not
know who you are why don't you give a
little context of a little bit about
your career and who you are sure my name
is jewel it's my real name and these are
my real teeth nobody asks me that but I
just thought I'd throw it out there I'm
from Alaska and my family were pioneers
I grew up on a homestead which means I
grew up eating only what I could kill or
kin so my think aim in really handy I
didn't actually see it taught me
resilience it taught me grit it taught
me how to grind it taught me self-esteem
from the inside out which is being able
to understand that you're capable
because you've been given the
opportunity to struggle which is a real
blessing and I ended up moving out of
fifteen ended up homeless at 18 was
shoplift why'd you why'd you originally
move out of 15 my dad was abusive and so
I decided I would just live in a cabin
by myself
we had been pretty transit moved around
a lot and been taking care of myself
quite a long time and so I wanted to do
it on my own without somebody in the
cabin besides myself so too young to
drive I was hitchhiking in to work at a
pretty young age working multiple jobs
where in Homer Alaska and then I got a
scholarship to an amazing art school and
a roundabout way in Michigan I was able
to graduate from high school yeah me
most importantly if I look back on my
life I knew that at 15 I should have
been a statistic when I was homeless I
ended up homeless
for about a year when I was 18 I turned
down the advances of my boss and when I
wouldn't have sex with him he wouldn't
give me my paycheck and so I thought no
big deal living my car for a couple
months I'll get back on my feet but then
the car I was living in that stolen and
so that's how I ended up homeless and I
started having panic attacks I began
shoplifting a lot so I found a coffee
shop that was going out of business and
I said hey before you close your doors
give me two weeks and give me all the
door money and you can have all the
coffee and sales and food and so we
struck a deal and I suddenly had to go
out and get a following and I had to
write a bunch of songs because I grew up
singing cover songs with my dad so I
wrote and wrote and wrote and handed out
flyers I hustled I had two people in my
coffee shop first night and I sang a
five hour set and I sing my heart out
and what I learned
that I was very lonely and a lot of
people are lonely and I deserved to be
lonely because I only told truth in one
place and it was in a notebook that
nobody read and I decided to take a risk
and be vulnerable and talk about what
was real and not hide from the truth and
so I poured all my feelings out in front
of these two surfers what's their hearts
and but if you're watching you know one
of the surfers please leave a comment
holy [ __ ] I was that dude yeah and then
the next week four people came the next
week seven I played there every Thursday
to try and have a very regular time and
then after about a year it was sold out
and people were standing outside the
windows standing in pouring rain for
five hours listening to me through a
window and a radio station put a bootleg
of mine on the air and ended up
requested and I got into the top ten
countdown down top ten countdown on 91x
in Sandy it's one of the biggest
stations in the country labels were like
who the heck is this girl on acoustic
guitar playing between Nirvana and
Soundgarden they all started showing up
so it was like being Cinderella
you know limousines were showing up
really yeah and so you'd think I would
jump at the opportunity to have a record
label or a record deal except I had just
found happiness and I was not going to
give it up and fame as a path so many
people lose their footing on it's
happening 2d rock he's changing so much
so you were really trying to be careful
yeah I had to ask myself some very
serious questions why am I doing this
it's very important to know if you want
to end up somewhere you have to know
where you want to end up then you have
to have a compass of knowing how to
navigate so for me it was it an artist
or famous I know I wanted to be an
artist nothing against Fame by the way
it's just which one do you want it's an
experience for your life I wanted to be
an artist so everyday I made decisions
based on being an artist not being
famous or rich and other kind of
interesting caveat is I was offered a
million dollar signing bonus and I
turned it down I had read a book called
everything you need to know about the
music business and I learned that it was
in advance and that you owed the advance
back I knew I was going to make a folk
record at the height of grunge I know
the odds of that working were incredibly
slim and so I basically bought my own
right
make my own music and I negotiated the
biggest back-end anybody had ever been
given and royalties and mechanical same
thing I did with crush it nice I love it
I didn't what I that's so funny yet
yourself how'd you find it if you're
good enough bet on yourself and I turned
down reality TV shows and a lot of short
cut things but there's no shortcut to
being great so I did six hundred seven
hundred shows a year and I did it for
years and I grinded it out and ended up
breaking through but yes I've always
looked at myself entrepreneurial II to
answer your question and I really do
it's great it's really great Tim you
said something earlier about you know
you've got to be right to be able to you
know do the right thing by others you
know I you know it was interesting and
you know this this is a we have we have
a interesting great long relationship
but I really wanted to use this medium
to publicly apologize to you this is
something I've done to you personally a
lot of times you know I am so thankful
for the life that I live I am such a
happy man because I really like have
crazy good intent and have been able to
execute it a bunch this is something
nobody knows here I'm excited for
everybody I'm Tyler and people that know
who I am and you know I know you know
who I am but I wanted to do it because I
thought it was important for me because
I want you to know how much it means to
me because I've done it a bunch of times
personally early in my career I was
giving a speech at blogs with balls
and I I think I got overzealous
I did get overzealous and I was talking
about hard work and hustle and in it I
said [ __ ] four hour work weeks you got
to work your ass off and the level of
intent was extremely low but in reality
it was just not the right thing to do
especially because out of all the people
I know under the thought that I haven't
offended or hurt or even did anything
slightly wrong to millions of people
that I have no respect for or compassion
for or or desire for friendship or how I
feel about them the thought that that
happened and I just want you to know cuz
I know you I've said it a bunch of times
you
privately but in in my everlasting quest
for you to know how deeply I'm hurt that
I could have done anything that hurt you
or miffed you in any certain way I
wanted to put it super out there into
the universe and never let there be any
confusion I admire you tremendously
I've really enjoyed our friendship
through the years and that is when I do
die that is something that will still
run through my I've lived it pretty good
I've lived it pretty good and have all
the right intents
I hated that that happened I hate that
that happened and I want you to know on
this big of a stage or at least my
little micro big stage that I mean it
with every ounce of my soul thank you
Gary accepted I know you do we've we've
talked about a person we've talked about
it personally so but it mean yes
obviously like now that like as I
continue get older there's not that many
people doing it yeah you know yeah so no
the the the level of I get put into a
lot of were a lot of people use my name
and associated with other names and I
have no interest but every time people
are like oh and you know when on Twitter
or in real life when could be like oh I
liked him and Gary and every time I'm
associated with your name it means a lot
to me thank you Gary welcome to ya man I
love you many adventures ahead a hundred
percent yeah really appreciate it
talk to me about the hawk
Aaron Pryor gonna bury through the other
dude I'm a big big and they don't know
who he is you're mad you missed social
media on the hawk missed just missed it
just like I said we we but God knows
best gotta know what he's doing he did
it for his reason and that's what I mean
me selfish a couple more but the horse
was a bad boy
John the Beast Mugabi John the Beast
Mugabi was a killer - and I had to
destroy him but he did kill her before
handle destroyed him
yes what about terry norris tear no it
was a very good fight a very technical
firearm I think you probably did a
little more sparring in his days because
it kind of got to him at the inion but I
before that a was a bad boy he couldn't
play any sport boxing basketball
football
have you seen Nigel Ben's kid yes he's
but he's drunk strong he's very strong
he don't have to take me Thursday as yet
but he's very strong so they keep
walking around technically he could be a
good fighter Eubanks kids even better
yeah you Thanksgivings kids off you
think with some conscious his son is
awesome yes they both were punches and
forgive the pun I know it's interesting
like that Julian Jackson the hawk his
kid didn't turn to be what he will know
it he was up beats a minutes you guys
want to see real knockouts real a house
that knockout on Terry Norris is so
vicious incredible back on ratio of
Jackson
that dude Julian Jackson and he got a
flattop like Patrick Ewing real quick
what's the best flip you've ever had the
best one
yeah like the biggest ROI like I bought
this bike at a garage sale for $40 and I
sold it for six thousand nine hundred no
I didn't have one like that give me a
give me a real [ __ ] good one
I found a Ferrari 348 spider in a guy's
garage and I was able to flip that I
bought it from him for twenty thousand
bucks because it didn't run and I was
able to flip it for one hundred and
thirteen thousand that was better than
the example I gave and how much work or
things did you have to put into it a bit
fresh gas and then start it up straight
up yeah with the fresh gas and battery
we're good to go by the way I could so
get caught on that cuz I don't
understand cars like by the way I that's
really interesting so I don't know if
you know this but like all these chachi
goes like so many people that watch me I
pushed them to this 2017 flip challenge
and it's interesting I know pop culture
so I'm good at like buying like
advertising or TV stuff buying it
knowing it's undervalued but so many of
the people that watch me have have a
little bit more handy skills like you
did maybe not for bikes and cars but
like whether it's electronics or things
that nature and hearing people on
Twitter and email and damning me on
Instagram of like I bought this I this
it didn't work it took me one minute
it was the battery it was this that I
flipped it for that it's a it's amazing
when you have a skill set to use that as
an arbitrage now it's really cool
every single day I make pretend that my
mother dad sister brother wife or
children are killed now I know this is a
different version of it I know it's a
little I know it's a little different us
they get stabbed in the eye sometimes
even in detail but I will tell you it's
very fleeting it usually happens but I
promise you I know it's a little
left-field it's insane what that
perspective does for me nothing and I
feel it's contra and I feel it and I
feel it in my soul and and and it just
makes every bad thing and by the way and
I'm sure for your business when you're
the last line of defense
you know how they say occupation on the
doctor form the last time I filled it
out I said firefighter because that's
what I think I do for a living
like it's just problems like when I get
done with this interview we look at my
phone seven problems seven fires to put
out like that's what I do for me it's
perspective like I don't understand how
people don't get that there's seven plus
billion people that there's so many
people that have it worse than you look
if you live in this country I've you
know if you don't know the people here I
care but if you live in poverty in this
country
you're the 1% you're not the 99 I know
who third the planet lives on two hours
and fifty cents a day nine hundred
dollars a year if you make it 18,000 a
year I don't want you to make eighteen
thousand but you got to start with
gratitude that you're one of the richest
humans on earth if they can't like in
the jar
hairiness man it's just about happiness
bro that's all that matters is your
happiness other people are gonna tell
you what they think you should do or
what they would do if they were you but
they're not you bro they're not you so
just be happy and do what you love stay
passionate you know be smart and have
fun and take risk and be a wuzzle wuzzle
is a 1984 cartoon where two animals were
in one animal be it was will be a look
at professional lacrosse player and a
[ __ ] doctor and grandma [ __ ]
Victor is thrilled swag dude I'm 41
lacrosse has been growing disgustingly
fast since I was 14 so be careful but it
doesn't matter be happy and execute on
your thing don't justify your dreams
execute on them actually what we was all
right Victor we got a go my man we wish
you well see it thank you
all right one more Dan that's crucial
yeah don't just like oh this is tight
this is fun right this is cool [ __ ] I'm
gonna see like ask logic in a couple of
weeks on you too I'm gonna be excited
you should do this man yeah it's fine
that's fun right yeah thank you you're
welcome this is a really good experience
it's a good way to scale interaction
with fans
I like this energy do you think we
should be like uh do you think we should
start a morning she'll like me and you
versus like Kelly and Michael I guess
they like me you said you want to do TV
I'll wear the dress I'll wear to wear it
all right here we go you know the
person's name or even catch it laFonda
laFonda you're on the askgaryvee what is
it
relax over there does sticking phones
and she other's pockets feel this Gary
being on the askgaryvee show with logic
[Music]
you can hear us in the background they
got excited
t-pain you get to ask the question today
everybody who comes on as guest gets to
ask the vaynernation
the question of the day this is an
opportunity for you to get market
research or curiosity of something
answered thousands of comments and
answers will show up that's exactly what
I thought was about to happen
all around the world and I will keep
asking this question until Neil deGrasse
Tyson Tyson answers this goddamn
question if we go back in time follow me
on this if we go back in time we know
the earth moves through the universe
right so the earth is moving
continuously if we go back in time I
feel science do we go back to where the
earth was at that time and we just
that's why I think this is why we do
this question come to your ever thought
about time travel into the stuff we're
always moving through time and space and
we go back in time do we go back to
where the earth was that's why we can
see time travelers because they just end
up in a [ __ ] void are you telling me
I could go back in time and stay alive
longer I'm just living in 1437 no okay
what are you saying saying that if the
earth is moving through the universe
when you go back in time I think you can
we establish when you go back inside
who's gone back in time
how have they gone back in time go ahead
there are time machines where they're in
the [ __ ] void where the earth used to
be they went back in time and obviously
died like in the void of space they
[ __ ] there's like honest warning on
Total Recall hey I blew up this great
it's a lot going
I've got footage I don't have footage so
if the earth is moving through the
universe when you go back in time do you
go back to where earth world or the
earth go back with I don't know if I've
ever been more curious to see the
answers and YouTube and Facebook TP I'm
so ready
I appreciate it absolutely drop you did
[Music]